[Music]
hi I'm Evan Carmichael
welcome to the edition of entrepreneur
tools where I highlight some of the
favorite tools that I use to run my
business today I want to talk about one
of my new favorite tools called LastPass
and what this does is help you remember
your passwords across all your different
pages for your different accounts and it
also helps you create secure new
passwords that it remembers on its own
automatically so this is my page of
favorite tools and I'm gonna just
quickly find LastPass to show you guys
what it's all about the two problems
that I found especially when you're
creating a whole bunch of different
online accounts if it's Twitter or
LinkedIn or whatever services you're
signing up for the more services I sign
up for I found that I was either using
the same password over and over and over
again which wasn't really a secure way
to do things or I would try to create
unique passwords but then I wouldn't
always remember what they were and I'd
have a notepad file to try to remember
everything and then it's searching
through that file so what LastPass does
is automatically remember the passwords
for you and will also help you generate
new passwords that are more secure when
you're sending for new services so give
you a quick look of what it looks like
I'm using Chrome here when you are
signed in to whatever browser you're
using you'll see that there's a little
LastPass extension at the top so this is
my last pass here it means that I've
signed in it's called LastPass because
you still have to actually remember what
your LastPass password is so you have
one password to remember that's how to
log into LastPass 6 to access all your
your passwords so you just have to
install the extension if you're using
Chrome or Firefox you can easily put it
in and that means now I'm logged in it
recognizes me and every time I sign into
a website it'll keep track of the
password if I wanted to
so why that's helpful let me load a new
tab here I'm gonna go to my dashboard
and what I'll find here these are the
tools that I use on a regular basis to
run my business and I can log into any
of them without having to remember my
password so let's take a look at buffer
for example buffer is a great way to
scheduled posts to your social media so
I'm not logged in here yet what I'm
gonna do here is just click use my
buffer account oh and it automatically
log me in for me again that's using
LastPass to see if I could slow it down
a little bit for you guys here so I'll
sign out I'll click on the use buffer
account and what's gonna happen here is
it's gonna remember my email and then
remember my password and this little
star means LastPass I see it matches the
symbol above so it unlock remembered
what my password was because I don't
remember what it was for buffer and then
I can just click sign in and
automatically remembers me and it'll
bring me into my account and you can see
I've got a few videos scheduled to go up
to my Twitter account so I'm really easy
way to remember your logins do another
quick example for you guys let me go to
my HootSuite so HootSuite is another
tool used to manage my social media
click on yesterday's tweets and you'll
quickly see a log in sometimes it's
really fast which is great for you as a
user you don't want it to really slow
down so you automatically pulled my
email and password and it logged me and
without me having to do any clicks or
anything in our life you took me right
to my account and now I'm logged into
HootSuite and I can check out all my
different streams and do whatever I want
to do so it's a great easy way to
automatically log in to all your
different accounts now what's gonna
happen is when you sign into an account
for the first time a little pop-up will
come up and say you want LastPass to
remember this password so you have the
option to enable it yes or no if you
don't want it to remember if you have
your friends coming over and they're
using your computer you don't wanna
remember their passwords then you can
turn it off but for the most part I
always want to turned on they wanted to
remember all my passwords filled the log
in the next thing that I find it really
helpful for is to create new secure
passwords for new sites that I want to
sign up for so let's do a Google search
to find a program to sign up for I think
I click the one here yeah so here's a
here's one that I want to sign up for
say an example I don't know who these
guys I'm just using a dummy case so this
is the sign up for a reseller program
this could be anything this could be a
new LinkedIn account a new Twitter
account any new online service basically
any web site where you have to have a
login and password
it's LastPass will help you generate a
new password that is secure so if I'm
you know say I want to sell for these
guys and become a reseller disclosure I
have no idea who resellers panel is I
don't recommend what they do just just
using an example so here if I now have
to create a logger user login name and
password
I can click on my password and you'll
see that this new tab just popped up
here and this is from LastPass it's as
you create a new account you can use
generate so what I can do here is I can
either create my own password or I can
have LastPass automatically create one
for me if I click generate it'll come up
with a nice you know unique password
that is pretty strong a combination of
letters and numbers and uppercase and
lowercase and that's great I would never
remember that but last house is gonna do
it for me I just click accept and it
usually brings it back into here so I
think it's because I oh there we go
so it shows it ID automatically input it
into both the password and retake
password and then as I log into the site
of the automatically save it for me and
I never have to worry about what my
password is for this new services now
I'm not you're going to sign up but just
so you get the idea of how it works it's
a great way to create new passwords now
if you you know are on a different
computer and you need to find out what
your password is for a certain program
you can always go to your LastPass and
you can sign in and this is the one
password that you actually have to
remember so let's say as I sign in here
it'll make me put in my password I could
type that in and it'll show a list of
all the different accounts that I've
used on LastPass and you can see I've
got a lot of different accounts
passwords that I have saved with my
LastPass so it's great and if I ever
need to log into any of these and see
what
the password is I can easily just by
clicking on the link so a great way if
you're not on your computer to be able
to go in and find that the password that
you need the last thing that I really
like about LastPass and why I
highlighted on one of my favorite tools
is if you are using multiple computers
or multiple devices it's a great way to
transfer passwords in between your
programs so me personally I use a laptop
at home and when I'm traveling I have a
desktop at the office and I also use an
iPad while I'm mobile and when I create
a new account on one computer it
automatically updates my last passes
across my other computer and across my
mobile device on my iPad so it's great
so I don't have to actually remember it
so if you for most passwords there's an
option within a browser to build a
remember it for you but I like LastPass
better because I demand AIT's all of my
different computers and devices with an
iPad you have a special app that you
load it's a browser it's the it's the
last pass browser and if you try to
access any of your sites it will
remember all of your passwords for you
and great idea because I found when I'm
traveling in mobile and I have my iPad
and it may not be saved in the browser
history I can easily get into all the
programs and all the websites that I
need to because it has my password
remember so it's a quick way to be able
to again remember all of your passwords
and automatically log you into all your
different programs it's also a great way
to generate new passwords that are
secure so you don't have the same
password for everything and if you need
remote access you can always log in to
find out your different passwords and
it's also awesome for multiple computers
and across devices so that's why I love
LastPass if you guys have used LastPass
or gonna give it a try feel free to
leave it in the comments below or if you
have a question I always check out those
comments and love to be able to answer
them for you and of course if you liked
the video please give it a thumbs up
below it makes me want to do more of
these videos for you guys and hopefully
these tools are helping you give you new
ideas to run and grow your business so
thank you and I'll see you on the next
episode
[Music]
you
[Music]